oh purple
hoods and green outfits yes well the
spider-man trailers continues
with more plot details from spider
warren this is the
version of a trailer for now you know
this will suffice this will
this will satiate the spider buds butter
buds being you know like it's a
taste but that's the thing that the
reference i was making spider-man no am
plot details for toby and andrew i did
hear that there were some like new plot
details that came out that were from
good sources recently not just some like
reddit leaks or something like that
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we actually have quite a bit of
information about spider-man no way home
specifically involving
andrew garfield and toby maguire when
they are going to be
appearing in the film and what type of
role they are going to have in the film
also a bit of information about what the
villains are going to look like
and a little bit more information about
that trailer and the great thing
is that all of these reports today are
coming from very legitimate sources
and i think some fans might not
particularly enjoy this report
especially if you are a tom holland
spider-man fan if he is your favorite
you may not like this report however if
you are
toby mcguire spider-man fan then you
probably will like this report
so let's go on with this first report
and this first report is coming from
daniel richmond or daniel rbk
reliable reliable guy
the first part is when daniel replied to
a tweet on twitter
somebody asked him if toby is a
supporting role or
a action cameo and his reply was i heard
that from the moment they appear in the
movie toby and andrew become
co-leads to holland now this is the
report that i was talking about in the
beginning where i stated
especially if you are a tom holland fan
a lot of people were kind of upset with
the doctor strange announcement when
they stated that doctor strange was
going to be appearing in spiderman no
way home as sort of a mentor for peter
parker
a lot of people were pretty upset about
this because they want tom holland
spider-man to be on his own
in spider-man homecoming he had tony
stark in civil war
avengers end game and avengers infinity
war again he had tony stark
even though he saved tony's life at one
point and in game okay
guys listen now we did a video not long
ago talking about our honest concerns
for spider-man no way home one of them
being
that this might not feel like a tom
holland film a peter parker tom holland
film so i get where warren's coming from
and
nine times out of ten i'm likely to just
be like yes at the end of the day if
that is in fact true
that if there are co-leads to him most
of the spotlight will be given to them
that doesn't mean tom holland wouldn't
be the lead still
but the spotlight and the most talked
about things would be about them however
i'm also optimistic because i am
reminded of spider-man into the
spider-verse where you had
a spider-man miles morales and there's a
bunch of other spider-man and it still
felt like a miles morales movie so
i'm holding out faith that even if this
if this is true
that it could still feel like a you know
tom holland-led movie but more toby and
andrew why would i complain about that
well maybe they'll bring his character
out having more spider-man around maybe
could help deconstruct peter that much
further
kind of like miles morales spider-man of
survivors yeah exactly
and then in spider-man 5 from home he
had another mentor and that mentor was
really happy
mysterio faked it for a while and peter
was pretty happy to have him as a mentor
but of course that played out
but happy brought the plane brought the
new suits gave him the pep talk and that
was fine because that was a little bit
less mentorship than he had in the
previous film and fans really wanted to
see spider-man go out on his own
in spider-man no way home but it doesn't
appear that's going to be the case
now it looks like he's not only going to
have doctor strange but also toby
mcguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man as well
fighting right beside him however don't
get too upset about this yet because if
we think about this
it kind of makes sense if we consider
what the movie is really going to be
about there's a bunch of villains that
are coming from
the movie villains there's going to be a
multiversal problem
right there will be villains coming into
the main universe from
other different universes and some of
these villains are going to be a little
bit more beyond our peter parker a
little bit more for him to handle and if
you consider the fact that there are
going to be
like six seven villains in this film
essentially the sinister six
he's going to need some help peter has
come a long way but he is definitely
going to need some help to take on
six or seven villains alone and it won't
be the avengers
pretty soon because the second half of
this report is replying to daniel
stating that andrew and toby are going
to be co-leads a person then said
awesome i hope they come
halfway through instead of the end in
which daniel replied
they are so toby and andrew are
seemingly going to appear
halfway through the film which would
make sense as far as the movie is
concerned if you're going to have a
bunch of villains breaking out from the
multiverse it would make sense that the
other heroes come at the same time
or instead at the same time what i could
see being the situation
instead of like all the villains are
here oh thank god other spider-man
showed up at the same time too
i think he would probably be in a
position if all these villains are set
to appear like we know of a few for sure
but you know there's others rumor that
are not 100 confirmed yet i'd imagine
that in the first act of act two that's
when all the other villains start
showing up
and it's becoming increasingly difficult
for peter parker
tom holland to be handling this yeah and
then eventually
like around the midpoint where it looks
like based off of screenplay structure
right imagine
is the midpoint is when they would show
up being like oh thank god solution but
then things somehow start getting worse
from there what looks like a solution
actually could be
leading down uh uh the the the downfall
before the all's lost moment and the
dark kind of the soul and the finale of
the
film
you've got this whole thing beated out
yeah if that is i can see it working
that way yeah yeah one i can and i can
also see just an emotional dynamic of
like okay this might be too much for tom
hall and spider-man to handle plus you'd
have these two
other spider-man for whom they kind of
would feel responsible for
stepping in and taking care of these
particular villains from their universe
you know
exactly yeah they were like fighting
them like where'd they go i want to keep
my fight going well yeah
i'm sure they would be willing when they
figure out what's actually going
on and from this moment where all of the
villains come from different universes
and we get toby and andrew this is
really where dr
strange's role comes in obviously doctor
strange 2 the multiverse of madness is
going to be dealing with the multiverse
in
madness which is seemingly going to
start in loki and keep in mind
michael waldron who wrote loki and
doctor strange ii
told me personally when i interviewed
him that there are some things
in loki that will affect doctor strange
too which of course will in turn affect
spider-man no way home
at the center of it all at the center of
the moon exploding dr strange is there
and his focus in spider-man knowing home
is probably going to be
figuring out how to get these villains
back so i wouldn't expect to see
a ton of him most of the focus should be
on tom holland at first
a little bit of doctor strange and then
on the three spider-man sounds like what
they'd be doing with like doctor strange
in this movie
while directly affecting the plot of no
way home is that in some ways it would
serve as the ultimate
setup for multiverse of madness sort of
like the prequel well yeah he's gonna
hand the ball off to doctor strange
because whatever happens in this movie
is gonna get so out of hand that it's
like this isn't a peter problem anymore
this isn't a new york issue this is a
world
and also space time and spiritual realms
problems but for that to work you would
have to be more than just some cameo
appearance he'd had to absolutely
serve as like a supporting character in
the film but we'll see we'll see
doctor strange may even bring in the
other spider-man himself
to help our peter parker that maybe
of course if i hear anything i'll update
you and as far as the villains are
concerned daniel did put out another
reminder in a tweet that the green
goblin is going to be the main villain
of the film
and speaking of villains it looks like
we got a little bit more info today on
what they're going to look like
and this report is coming from superhero
theorists at murphy's multiverse.com
and the people that come in with some
pretty clutch leaks
specifically superhero theorists and we
got some information from them
replying to a tweet that said all i want
is a more accurate looking
goblin not that power ranger bs we got
from the first film
in which superhero theorists replied
expect the old
purple hoods and creed outfits yellow
shirts and creatures
yes purple pants and lab coats green
shirts and khakis and trench coats with
tentacles will all be in season
now obviously this is a description of
what some of the villains are going to
look like
i loved it hearing just the purple
outfits that's the perfect phrase
oh everyone's going to have a classic
loki but would it look
so much like the comic or what we've
seen from like the animated
shows which are inspired by the comics
because it's so mechanical what he wears
before
yeah uh green goblin specifically that
makes me super curious yeah cause i'm
like
expect the old preparer for the new so
is it gonna be a hybrid of like
something yeah that's mechanized and
practical but also that's way more
resembling
of the classic look or is it gonna be
like there's an interlude where like all
the sinister six are in their comic book
accurate costumes
yes or something like i can see the
possibility for either almost
i really like the way alfred molina
looks in um
spider-man 2 but you know like getting
some more of the colors into his outfit
oh man if they have like the colorful
outfits i didn't even think about that
would be nuts
yeah i mean they said electro is getting
a recoloration yeah so maybe it's just a
byproduct of the multiverse but i want
to specifically focus on the green
goblin because it looks like there's
going to be a key difference between the
green goblin we see
in this film and what we saw before in
the past the description for the green
goblin is purple hoods
oh come on that looks so great implies
that the green goblin is not going to
have a helmet or a mask
in fact in another tweet superhero
theorist said one of the things that
scared me as a kid with defoe's
green goblin was that we never actually
saw his face when he was green goblin
except for a few times and he was able
to strike fear with just his voice alone
imagine what he'll look like now when he
doesn't have the mask
now at one point in time there were
reports stating that the villains were
going to be taking from their respective
universes right before they die
and if this is true that means the green
goblin did not have a mask on right
before he died in the very first
spiderman give me a purple hood
i need to mix up my color palaces but if
it is true that would explain why the
green goblin has no mask
and he apparently is going to be wearing
a purple hood now of course as i said
there has been a little bit of a trailer
update and i wouldn't leave you without
talking about that
now this report comes from again daniel
richmond and he is extremely accurate
when it comes to trailers and
yesterday on twitter he said to be clear
i usually hear
a few days before nothing yet so likely
not dropping this week and was told not
to expect good because we're working on
a little opening sketch for the trigger
rigs
nice to get some buffer very accurately
players are dropping as well he was
accurate about
the eternals etc and this person
basically stated the same thing
haven't heard anything yet and if it was
coming out soon i would have
so sadly i wouldn't expect it soon now i
have heard reports stating that it could
be coming with black widow
but i personally actually think that
they would wait until loki is over with
before releasing the trailer because i
think the ending is really going to set
up the multiverse of madness and
spider-verse and again daniel's very
accurate with trailer releases
and my guys said the same thing it'd be
cool if sony plays ball
instead this time far from home trailer
[ __ ] yeah rumors marvel's controlling
the marketing a bit more
or mad about this report that states
toby mcguire and
airfield are going to be co-leads and
coming in about halfway through the film
let me know in the comments down below
and don't forget to like this video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest spider-man or mcu videos
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
i'll just end it with saying that i'd be
more befuddled
if they were co-leads from like 15 to 20
minutes into the movie if it's halfway
through
that's not a big deal to me because
because it gives time to still
really establish who your main character
is in the first in your first half of
the movie
right but guys what do you think about
this report here
these are reliable sources he was
talking these are very like
a lot of how we've been able to be on
top of things
especially with like breaking news or
breaking trailer information
has been specifically from the sources
he listed here so
i i absolutely trust these sources too
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do a
daniel gallacher daniel i just wanted to
say
thanks for coming to our live stream the
other day for some reason
spider-man stories make me think of you
because of the place
we're not going to talk about i think of
chemicals exploding and then you getting
insane powers and then having to mask
your scottish accent to do an american
accent when you finally get cast in some
kind of superhero-like scenario because
let's face it most of
the greatest heroes have american
accents but daniel
this is getting off-road thanks again
for just show like it was cool to know
that in the middle of our afternoon
probably
at the point in time in your day where
you would want to just crash and go to
sleep you were listening
and hanging out with us and you know it
made me feel like the world wasn't such
a big multiversal place but a little
tiny dot where we could all hang out
together so i hope you're doing well and
uh
thanks again for showing up and showing
your support means a
thank
lot
[Music]